[Musique]
ça recrute sur tv78 votre nouvelle
émission qui parle emploi dans le
département et le bassin de 50 ans en
Eveline à chaque numéro son invité qui
vient parler de son secteur ou de son
entreprise qui embauche et on vous
donnera aussi des conseils en matière de
job pour trouver un job sur le
territoire et pour ce premier numéro
nous recevons Delphine Philippe girud
bonsoir bonsoir directrice territoriale
de Pôle Emploi yeline vous avez pris vos
fonctions depuis peu bah comment ça
s'est passé vos prises de fonction j'ai
pris mes fonctions fin juin début
juillet mais ça s'est très bien passé là
je prends connaissance du territoire des
acteurs locaux donc c'est danse on a
énormément d'événements mais vous l'avez
dit he notamment lié aux jop qui ont
lieu l'été prochain
donc je voilà je prends connaissance du
territoire un territoire riche très
dynamique et c'est intéressant et je
vous rencontre aujourd'hui j'en suis
ravi un territoire dynamique qu'on va
avoir l'occasion de présenter on va
parler des opportunités qui existent sur
ce territoire des evvelin des
opportunités aussi en lien vous l'avez
dit avec les jop Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques qui vont arrivriver en
2024 en France il y a plein
d'opportunités sur le territoire qui se
dessin et dans sa recrute je serai
accompagné aussi à chaque fois de Clara
de Frutos bonsoir claraons journaliste
économique de la rédaction de tv78 vous
allez nous présenter en fin d'émission
trois offres d'emploi et là on parle
concrètement des des opportunités aussi
en lien avec les j c'est ça j'en ai
sélectionné trois dans les Yvelines qui
tourn autour des Jeux Olympiques comme
on va en parler aujourd'hui dans cette
émission donc ce sera tout à l'heure
dans sa recrute et c'est parti pour ce
premier
numéro les opportunités d'emploi tout
d'abord dans le département des ivelines
alors c'est un département pour
présenter un petit peu sa carte
d'identité qui compte 1,4000 Milon
d'habitants 32000 entreprises même plus
de 32000 entreprises pour plus de 400000
salariés le taux de chômage s'élevait à
6,3 % au 2e semestre 2023 est-ce qu'on
peut parler Delphine Philippe girud d'un
territoire dynamique en matière d'emploi
oui on peut parler d'un territoire
dynamique vous avez vous l'avez dit he
6,3 % de de chômage c'est peu s'approche
du du plein emploi on a une véritable
dynamique sur le 78 on a énormément
d'entreprises et on a des des secteurs
qu'on ne trouve pas partout ailleurs
notamment l'industrie on a un bassin
industriel fort qui se redynamise
également et tout l'enjeu pour nous
c'est aussi de permettre aux entreprises
de s'installer de grossir et et
deevenenir
peut-être redorer regonfler le bassin
industriel notamment sur le le nord du
du département mais pas seulement
puisquon a aussi beaucoup beaucoup de
demandes sur le transport la log
logistique l'hôtellerie restauration les
les secteurs le numérique également le
commerce bien sûr puisque le 78 est
aussi un territoire de de commerce et
puis le la santé l'action sociale
recrute aussi énormément alors il y a
aussi des des pôles j'imagine
géographiques qui sont très dynamiques
nous on parle beaucoup de 50 Anseline
sur tv78 ça fait partie de ces pôles ah
oui ça fait partie de ces pôles pour les
Yvelines et même pour l'île-de-fance
c'est un pôle d' activité économique
très fort où les opportunités sont
nombreuses vous avez commencé à en
parler c'est un territoire aussi où
l'industrie a une place forte alors
géographiquement c'est aussi un
territoire entre l'urbain et le rural il
y a un gros une grosse part de de
secteur agricole et ça se ressent sur
les secteurs qui recruent vous avez
parlé de l'industrie il y a cette ce
fleuve de la scène aussi qui passe
autour duquel c'est construit de de
nombreuses grand grandes entreprises de
d'industrie ça se ressent aussi oui ça
se ressent ça se ressent dans la
diversité à la fois des des secteurs ça
se ressent aussi sur la diversité au
niveau de la demande d'emploi
c'est-à-dire qu'on a des demandeurs
d'emploi qui sont aussi bien dans le 78
issus de quartier prioritaire de la
ville mais on a aussi des des personnes
qui sont issu d'un milieu social et
économique assez élevé on a une
accessibilité aussi euh à la à la
compétence via l'université notamment
donc on a vraiment un panel à la fois
d'entreprise de taille d'entreprise et
puis de demandeur d'emploi très variés
ce qui nous oblige aussi à avoir un
panel d'offre de service un spectre très
large et à travailler en collaboration
avec l'ensemble des partenaires du du
territoire et c'est tout l'enjeu sur les
mois à venir notamment parce qu'on est
territoire expérimental dans la
perspective de France travail qui arrive
en 2024 on aa l'occasion d'en parler un
peu plus tard dans les mois à venir sur
tv78 vous avez parlé des secteurs des
des métier qui recrute le plus dans dans
les ibin si on prend sur la dernière
année sur les dernières années écoulées
c'est c'est dans quel secteur qu'on
recrute le plus dans lesbin la santé
l'enseignement le bâtiment également
l'hôtellerie
restauration le transport on a
énormément de de demandes dans le le
transport on a la SAVAC hein par exemple
qui qui recrute beaucoup en ce moment
euh on a le numérique également et on
travaille aussi en collaboration avec
les organismes de formation et les
entreprises donc c'est assez assez varié
donc il y a beaucoup d'entreprises
beaucoup d'opportunités il y a aussi de
l'autre côté des universités des écoles
des organismes de formation est-ce que
les jeunes qui sont formés sur le
territoire des Ilin arrivent facilement
à à être embauchés dans les éin en
sortie d'études où justement il y a
encore des difficultés à à les amener à
à rencontrer de potentiels recruteurs h
alors ils arrivent facilement euh pas
forcément effectivement euh il faut ils
ont tous besoin d'un accompagnement qui
est pas forcément qui est pas forcément
le le même pour tous mais en tout cas
oui on a vraiment nécessité nous à faire
découvrir les métiers qui recrutent et
aussi à accompagner les entreprises à
élargir euh finalement le champ des
possibles et euh et leur spectre euh
parce qu'aujourd'hui la demande ne ne
colle pas forcément euh à l'offre et
donc c'est tout le le travail qu'on fait
au quotidien c'est qu'est-ce qu'on peut
mettre en place pour que finalement
peut-être que les euh les compétences
qui manqueraient ou euh les les écarts
qu'il y a aujourd'hui puisse être comblé
via de l'accompagnement via de la
formation via du tutorat et euh pole
emploi et là pour accompagner les
entreprises justement euh à à embaucher
dans ces conditions un dernier Moot
avant qu'on parle des opportunités en
matière de jeux olympiques sur le
territoire des ielines on le disait tout
à l'heure un territoire qui compte 6,3 %
de taux de chômage au au 2e semestre
2023 le profil de ces demandeurs
d'emploi quel est-il dans les ivelines
on n on n'a pas je dirais un profil type
mais euh globalement on a beaucoup
aujourd'hui de demandeurs d'emploi qui
sont inscrits sur les listes de
demandeurs d'emploi depuis euh un
certain temps ce qu'on appelle des
demandeurs d'emploi de longue durée ou
de très longue durée et donc c'est euh
souvent des personnes qui sont
relativement éloignées de l'emploi et
euh qui nécessite euh de de retrouver
une connexion avec le marché du travail
et c'est en ça qu'on a besoin de
travailler en lien et en collaboration
en partenariat fort avec les entreprises
et les groupements euh d'entrepris du
territoire tel que la CPME la CCI euh
les entreprises s'engagent
de manière à ce que elles fassent
connaître leur métier qu'ell fasse
connaître leur secteur et puis que nous
on puisse accompagner ces demandeurs sur
ces offres là et puis sur cette rendre
attractif en fait des des métiers qui
sont peut-être mal connus ou peu connus
C PME Confédération des petites et
moyennes entreprises et CCI Chambre de
Commerce et d'industri on disait de
nouvelles opportunités se créent sur le
territoire avec l'organisation des Jeux
olympiques de Paris 200 24 en trou ce
sont 38000 offres d'emploi qui sont à
pourvoir en en Île-de-France et il y
aura donc cet événement qui aura lieu le
21 novembre 2023 donc de 10h à 17h au
Vélodrome de 550 Anin les jeux recrutes
qui donc va proposer les jeux recrutes
même vont proposer toute cette offre on
va dire disponible en matière de jeux
olympiques sur sur le territoire
sorganisé justement par vous Paul emploi
Paris 2024 et aussi l'agglomération de
50 ans nvin mais pourquoi tout
simplement organiser cette événements
est-ce que les les besoins sont ne sont
pas encore totalement pourvus en la
matière non les besoins ne sont pas
encore totalement pourvus là on va
parler de de 700 offres qui vont être
mises à disposition à l'affiche je
dirais le jour J donc le le 21
novembre on a nécessité aussi encore à
parler de de cet événement et puis
encore une fois à faire connaître les
métiers donc on va avoir sur cet
événement euh je dirais plusieurs volets
on a à la fois des job dating purement
et simplement on a aussi de la
découverte des de métiers qui va pouvoir
se faire via des casques virtuel VI a
des témoignages aussi d'entreprise de
salariés et puis euh on on va avoir
aussi des ce qu'on appelle donc des du
stade vers l'emploi c'est euh une
nouvelle forme une forme un petit peu
différente euh de de recruter on va
avoir des recruteurs qui vont être là
avec des demandeurs d'emploi passer la
journée
ensemble et qui via le sport VI a des
activités sportives de manière anonyme
sans se connaître
bon finalement faire une activité
sportive ensemble et en deuxème partie
de de journé on va faire tomber les
masques on saura qui sont les recruteurs
et ça permettra à chacun de de faire un
speed dating de manière à approfondir
peut-être ce qu'on a pu déjà percevoir
lors des des épreuves sportives alors
vous parliez des 700 offres disponibles
pour cet événement les jeux recrutes de
quel type d'emploi parle-ton est-ce que
ce sont des emplois spécifiques aux Jeux
Olympiques qui vont s'étendre dans la
durée et dans quel secteur surtout alors
c'est des c'est à la fois bien sûr des
offres qui sont directement liées aux
Jeux olympiques mais sur des métiers
dont on a besoin tout le temps donc on
va avoir du transport on va avoir de la
logistique tout ce ce qui est on va
avoir aussi de
l'événementiel des des des métiers liés
au médias aussi on va avoir tout ce qui
est dans la
restauration cuisinier
serveur on a vraiment on a aussi des
métiers dans dans l'informatique on a
tous les métiers de la sécurité donc le
spectre est
large de l'agent de sécurité au manager
donc on a quand même sur cet événement
des métiers qui sont en lien direct avec
les événements qui vont nous toucher
directement sur le 78 via les GI mais
qui sont des métiers sur lesquels il y a
de l'emploi maintenant et il y en aura
évidemment après puisque c'est des
métiers qui recrutent de toute façon
indépendamment des JO donc ça veut dire
que dans cette journée il y aura des des
embauches concrètement oui ah j' journé
on est là pour ça en tout cas et donc on
l'a dit le spectre est large donc on
peut c'est des métiers qui vont demander
de la qualification ou aussi peu de
qualification ça va aussi euh varier
l'idée c'est aussi qu'on puisse faire
repérer que des entreprises puissent
repérer il va y avoir les embauches qui
peuvent se faire directement en fin de
journée mais il y a aussi du repérage de
potentiel de posture et sur des
demandeurs d'emploi qu'on va pouvoir
former d'ici à l'embauche et d' on
rappelle donc c'est le 21 novembre du
côté du Vélodrome national de 5 an enine
la préinscription est obligatoire pour
se faire c'est très simple il suffit de
se rendre sur le site internet
lesjeuxrecrut.org
et on va terminer cette émission Clara
justement avec des opportunités d'emploi
alors on parlait avec Delphine Philippe
girud des offres liées aux Jeux
olympiques et justement vous avez
sélectionné pour nous trois offres
d'emploi dans le département desvin qui
sont directement liés avec
l'organisation de ces Jeux Olympique
c'est exact j'en ai sélectionné trois
donc pour la plupart elles font partie
des six grands secteurs qui recrutent
activement l'hôtellerie restauration la
sécurité privée le tourisme les
transports et logistique euh les
fonctions support et euh le sport
évidemment donc par exemple sodexoive
qui a été créé par l'entreprise de
restauration collective à loocation des
jeux olympiques propose un poste en CDI
de mître d'hôtel à Clairefontaine en
Eveline donc là vos missions seront de
veiller à la qualité du service à table
gérer le personnel de service répartir
superviser et appliquer des tâches de
services à table d'entretien euh des
locaux de mise en place de dans les sal
à manger euh faciliter et réguler les
les relations de travail entre le
personnel de salle et ceux de la cuisine
en ce qui concerne les compétences il
est simplement demandé d'avoir une
qualification en agent de maîtrise et le
salaire brut mensuel est de 2300 € à 200
€ sur 12 mois donc ce deexo a d'autres
besoins aussi en vue de Paris 2024 je
vais demander juste à la technique en
régie de retirer la le petit bandeau
pour qu'on puisse avoir toutes lesé
missions toutes les compétences à chaque
fois qui qui s'affiche mais en tout cas
sexo à d'autres besoin en vue de Paris
2024 exact Sodexo est très active sur
cesg 2024 le deuxième poste que je vous
propose est un poste d'officier en CDD à
Versailles pour une durée d'une à 2 mois
vous serez amené à accompagner le
responsable des prestations annexes dans
la réalisation des événements et
prestations garantir la qualité des
prestations afin de délivrer une bonne
une bonne qualité de service effectuer
les repérages techniques sur les lieux
pour déterminer les besoins matériels et
humains accompagner évidemment les
clients sur les les événements faire de
votre sécurité et C de votre équipe une
priorité et en ce qui concerne les
compétences du coup en ce qui concerne
les compétences attention d'abord pardon
j'ai oublié de de le préciser cette
offre n'est valable que pour la période
des Jeux olympiques et paralympiques
c'est-à-dire du 1er juillet au 11
septembre 2024 et donc pour les
compétences requises le recuteur demande
de la rigueur de l'organisation et avoir
une bonne appétten relationnelle le
salaire mensuel brut là ici est de
1929 EUR 24 par mois et donc des besoins
en matière d'événementiel d'hôtellerie
vous en avez parlé de restauration
également et vous allez terminer par une
offre en matière de sécurité Paris que
c'est l'autre secteur aussi qui recrute
exact le trisème emploi est un poste de
G gestionnaire pardon de flotte au
chaîné recancour il s'agit là d'un CDD
d'un an proposé par la direction de
l'innovation de la logistique et des
technologies de la préfecture de Paris
là vous serez amené à travailler sur
plusieurs points la création de plan
d'équipement de suivi de livraison euh
pour les JO 2024 et le contrôle de
validité euh des besoins la Constitution
aussi d'un carnet de bord vous serez
aussi amené à contrôler les techniques
vlpl et vu euh mettre à jour des données
des véhicules gérer les demandes
d'immatriculation des parcs et aussi
gérer les véhicules qui seront saisis
donc ça c'est pour les missions et les
compétences et pour les compétences le
poste demander enfin demande pardon
d'être organisé d'analyser et de savoir
travailler en équipe la rigueur et la
communication l'adop la l' anticipation
seront également deises je vais y
arriver euh des compétences
rédactionnelles informatiques et
bureautiques seront également requises
euh il est aussi demandé d'avoir le
permis B et le salaire mensuel net est
là de 1611 €. donc évidemment toutes les
offres vous pourourez les trouver sur le
site emploi 2024 et si vous cherchez
d'autres offles d'emploi dans les
evening qui sont en dehors des JO vous
pouvez vous diriger vers le le site de
skiemploi voilà emploi 2024.fr
skiemploi.fr de ressources on peut
trouver effectivement des offres
d'emploi près de chez vous merci Clara
merci à vous également Delphine PhIP
Girot de nous avoir accompagné sur ce
premier numéro de sa recrute je rappelle
vous êtes directrice territoriale de PUL
emploi 78 pôul emploi qui dans les
prochains numéros à partir du prochain
numéro va vous proposer des conseils
pour trouver un job voilà c'est la fin
de ce premier numéro de sa recrute merci
de nous avoir suivi très belle soirée
sur
[Musique]
tv78